Якби хтось казав мені два роки тому що
Німеччина постачатиме важке озброєння на
суму від трьох до п'яти мільярдів євро я
був це не повірив Ми не хочемо щоб наша
зброя використовувалася для перетину
російського кордону
Україна суверенна країна і тільки її
самі вирішувати Коли настане час для
переговорів ви згадали що Німеччині
необхідно переглянути свою політику
експорту зброї щоб підтримати країни
партнери демократичні держави у їхніх
законних інтересах самооборони То чого
саме ви сподіваєтеся досягти чи йдеться
про те що Німеччина має переглянути
питання про те кому постачає свою зброю
що ж 24 лютого Минулого року Ми
прокинулися зовсім іншому світі тому нам
варто переосмислити нашу політику
останніх десятиліть і ми це робимо
німецьке суспільство та німецька
політика справді змінилася Якби хтось
казав мені два роки тому що Німеччина
постачатиме важке озброєння на суму від
трьох до п'яти мільярдів євро я був це
не повірив вже зараз видно Наскільки
змінилася громадська думка та політика
Німеччини
І звісно як я вже казав необхідно
знизити ризик це означає що ми повинні
об'єднати усі країни світу які хочуть і
здатні захищати правила або порядок щоб
грунтується на правилах
в Україні звісно є німецька зброя
наприклад ви поставили їм танки і є
побоювання що Україна може використати
цю зброю щоб зайти на територію Росії
тепер якщо у вас правильно розумію ви
стверджуєте що Україна має на це право з
метою самооборони але які у вас є
гарантії що танк Леопард німецького
виробництва не в'їде наприклад до
Белгорода І що буде якщо це станеться
я абсолютно довіряю нашим українським
партнерам Я завжди наголошую що
міжнародне право дозволяє Україні це
робити але з іншого боку Німеччина і США
наприклад також завжди наголошували що
ми не хочемо щоб наша зброя
використовувалася для перетину
російського кордону
Тож у цьому різниця між позиціями але я
абсолютно упевнений що Україна надійний
партнер і я не маю жодних сигналів про
зворотне але проблема залишається можна
його варто приділяти надто багато уваги
цьому питанню зараз на час і не місце
тут в Індонезії міркувати про те що
зараз Можна що ні не
навіть попри те що ми знаходимося в Азії
якщо до крилатих ракет Таурус чи отримає
їх Україну
не зараз і ми насправді поки не
розглядаємо таку можливість
А про яку роль думає Німеччина в питанні
коаліції щодо винищувачів про роль
спостерігача Чи йдеться про більш
активну участь як того хоче президент
Зеленський
Ми якраз перебуваємо на етапі
переосмислення і перевірки того що
можливо і що ми хочемо і можемо зробити
і я думаю ми визначимося Протягом
наступних двох тижнів
зараз звичайно велику роль у дискусіях
тут в Азії відіграє війна Росії проти
України і Ви часто чуєте питання Що
зробила Німеччина щоб зупинити цю війну
Наскільки важко вам переконати тут своїх
колег у тому що негайне припинення вогню
не є рішенням що ви їм кажете
Я кажу партнерам що негайне припинення
вогню означатиме лише те що Росія
продовжить свою агресію вони підуть зі
своєю агресією далі і зрештою досягнуть
успіху я лише дві країни які можуть
закінчити цю війну перше - це Росія якщо
вона виведе свої війська з України то
війна закінчиться у той самий момент Але
якщо ми припинимо постачання зброї до
України це означатиме що завтра України
не буде тож Це не вихід Україна
суверенна країна і тільки її самій
вирішувати Коли настане час для
переговорів або чогось ще це не залежить
від нас
Чи є у вас відчуття що вони не розуміють
так Але не всі це розуміють або
приймають Але більшість з них розуміє
тому що я завжди кажу їм Щоб ви зробили
в такій самій ситуації чого б ви
очікували від ваших партнерів від ваших
союзників у світі які скажуть вам що ви
повинні капітулювати здатися яке рішення
ні принаймні у цей момент наші партнери
розуміють
І останнє запитання щодо перспектив
вашої наступної поїздки до Індії Індія
дуже залежить від Росії коли йдеться про
зброю Чи хочете ви це змінити чи
збираєтеся ви збільшити продаж німецької
зброї
Німеччина не мусить змінювати це
самостійно це не має робити лише
Німеччина це питання яке ми маємо
вирішувати спільно з іншими партнерами
але звісно у довгостроковій перспективі
Ми не можемо бути зацікавлені в тому щоб
Індія настільки залежала від поставок
російської зброї чи інших матеріалів
тому ми повинні думати про те що ми
можемо зробити
оріус центри оборони Німеччини дякую вам
дуже дякую